trying to find a game about first times
this is a movie about first time yes I'm
gonna give each of you a card and you
should tell your co-stars something that
you did for the first time and describe
it and see if they can guess what it's
like cheboub they're planning on losing
their virginity on prom night
[Music]
give me the Oh Mikasa he started giving
me a little bit of mom made her start
off with and I was like cover up and and
it was like you know hard around
and hard and I didn't really look but I
may have and I'm cute um then he said
give me some lip gloss on the tips or
doesn't Oh Sonny filmed a bunch I can
see John Cena's bet on seven it's a
high-traffic flea market the corner of
Tijuana I had driven there my own car
was a 91 Continental none of the windows
worked into the AC it's hot that day
first time you had diarrhea it's hot
that day they didn't speak Spanish stuck
in a tent with no roof talking to men in
masks diarrhea lacing thigh-high boots
telling me what they're going to do to
me when they get me so as the day
proceeds and I get more nervous I begin
taking off more of my clothes there I
find myself did you have diarrhea no I
did not but I have a story about having
diarrhea wrestling match tights with a
color of this arm oh good and then or
sudden they work yep what those things
would be worth now
I'll do anything for my daughter what
about a little chugging contest bringing
that westward but Chuck
on the count of three
[Music]
[Music]